faugh in washington parts of the
government that were shut down for 35
days are now open again but President
Trump says he doubts the uncertainty is
over in a weekend interview the
president said the chances of
congressional negotiators reaching a
budget deal are less than 50/50
he also said he wouldn't rule out
another shutdown if Congress doesn't
give him the 5.7 billion dollars he
wants for a border wall Nancy Cordes is
on Capitol Hill Nancy good Monday
morning to you good morning so the
government is open again at least for
the next three weeks but it's limping
this is the first weeks a week of tax
season and the IRS is going to be
struggling to get returns out to some
Americans on time and a group of
lawmakers is now racing to find a
compromise and up against a very a
deadline that's coming up fast he's
willing to do whatever it takes to
secure the border acting White House
chief of staff Mick Mulvaney warned
there will be consequences if the two
sides don't cut a border deal fast is
the president really prepared to shut
down the government again in three weeks
yeah I think he actually is 17
congressional leaders eight Republicans
and nine Democrats have less than three
weeks to fulfill a vague mission beef up
border security funding by an
unspecified amount we really have no
choice but to build a powerful wall the
president said Friday that if Congress
doesn't boost funding he'll declare a
national emergency or allow another
partial shutdown even though many in his
party still feel burned by the last one
shutdowns are never good policy ever
according to S&P the shutdown has cost
the US economy six billion dollars
that's more than the 5.7 billion
president Trump requested for the border
wall at the heart of this dispute a
federal watchdog determined it could
take the IRS at least a year to get back
to normal after five million pieces of
mail went unopened it's gonna be massive
ketchup at this point Michelle Harris is
one of thousands of IRS workers who
were furloughed for 35 days she put off
emergency dental work and car repairs
and still hasn't gotten her back pay she
says some of her colleagues quit I know
that it was more than people could
handle and they put in their notice I
don't blame them the White House says
that federal workers will start to get
their back pay today and that all
overdue checks should go out by the end
of the week as for president Trump's
State of the Union address CBS News has
learned that February 5th is under
consideration as a makeup date but that
likes so much else around here is
currently uncertain and subject to
negotiation Nancy thank you so much